بين دفتي كتابه يرمي بحجاره تاره يفتخر
بقتله 25 عنصرا من طالبان ومره اخرى يعترف
عالجت غياب امي بالكوكايين
اعترافات يرويها الامير هاري في الكتاب
القنبله المسمى
حروف ورطت هاري وادخلته في دوامه الاوضاع
القانونيه في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
قد تصل به للترحيل من اراضيها
معضله قانونيه اقحم بها نفسه هاري باقراره
انه تناول جرعه من المخدرات ليذهب بها
معتركه احزانه على فقدان والدته الاميره
ديانا
لكن الامير هاري قد يفقد وضعه كمهاجر حيث
كشف استطلاع راي نشرته نيوزويك الامريكيه
ان
54% من عينه بلغت
شخص يعتقدون ان تاشيره اقامته يجب
مراجعتها من قبل وزاره الامن الداخلي بسبب
اعترافته الصادمه وفي سؤال اخر قالت نسبه
مماثله انهم شعروا ان الاميره كان على حق
في الافصاح عن تاريخه مع تعاطي المخدرات
في مذكراته طعن قانوني يواجهه هاري بعد
اقامه حظي بها لثلاث سنوات لن يخرجه من
امريكا فحسب وانما قد يضع له قيودا في
السفر منها واليها وربما المنع من التقدم
بطلب للحصول على الجنسيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات